pocas veces hay tanta expectativa en
torno a un discurso como en esta ocasión
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
llegó a ruanda buscando normalizar las
relaciones con este país sus lazos han
estado marcados por las tensiones en
torno al papel de parís en el genocidio
de 1994 desde el memorial de kigali en
donde yacen los restos de más de 250.000
víctimas de las 800.000 que dejó el
genocidio tutsi el mandatario admitió la
responsabilidad de francia mira fons
pero francia tiene un papel una historia
y una responsabilidad política en ruanda
y tiene un deber mirar la historia a la
cara y reconocer el sufrimiento que ha
infligido sobre el pueblo de ruanda al
permitir que el silencio prevalezca por
encima de la búsqueda de la verdad
durante mucho tiempo
francia es acusada de haber apoyado al
ejecutivo de la época con respaldo
logístico en marzo una comisión de
investigación de historiadores franceses
encontró que el país europeo tiene una
abrumadora responsabilidad por no haber
previsto la masacre
soy un si lenin
son aquellos quienes han atravesado la
noche los que pueden quizás perdonar y
darnos el regalo del perdón
son unas palabras que no son suficientes
para los supervivientes de la masacre
quienes lamentaron que el presidente
francés no haya pronunciado una disculpa
clara